bon moi y'a des trucs comme ça je
comprends pas franchement je ne
comprends pas voilà ça par exemple
voilà
voilà c'est immonde c'est vraiment je
m'en fous les éboueurs ne les respectent
pas mais c'est quand même dingue alors
c'est quand même dingue c'est qu'en plus
il ya la déchetterie qui est juste là
donc elle est même pas à 50 mètres pas
non je m'en fous je respecte pas ce
qu'ils travaillent je m'en fous voila
voila merci
on fait tous un peu des efforts on n'est
pas des ports voilà merci
il y aurait quand même beaucoup moins de
morts sur les routes si les gens rouler
sur les trottoirs
c'est une idée que tu viens d'avoir oui
enfin les trotteurs ont été créés pour
qui mais pour l'épauler pour les piétons
mais pour les protéger des accidents
l'arbre lui donc si le tueur comme une
bagnole qui foncent dessus on aura des
morts sur les trottoirs oui peut-être
mais quand même duré beaucoup moins
morts sur les routes
j'ai besoin de votre aide genre
maintenant d'urgence qu'est ce qui
t'arrive mapk et raclette des alpes je
suis personnellement ça c'est chiant et
de faux quoi 203 sandales à ça c'est pas
une dette c'est un pib c'est pour cela
que je lance ce matin un appel national
ou saas fee vous venez en ligne mais
enfin valoches tu peux pas dépenser de
l'argent que tu n'as pas et demander aux
français de t&d à rembourser des
républicains ne peuvent pas faire face à
ses dépenses un crédit vous engage et
doit être remboursé vérifiez vos
capacités de remboursement avant de vous
engager
sari way oui
les amis j'ai reçu beaucoup de messages
concernant la vidéo ou et le vîmes
poussée dans l'eau
concernant mais jordan que je portais au
pied vous étiez plus inquiet pour les
baskets que pour moi donc sachez que les
gens donnent gourmet très important
elles ont survécu
désir non non on va pas faire ça toute
la journée je vais pas te dire non toute
la journée un
nom ça suffit allez